we saw how Apple shares are now at a new
record high these positive analyst notes
from UBS from Goldman Sachs's Apple out
there communicating with analysts giving
them reason to be more often optimistic
one of the interesting things with some
earnings the other week they talked
about the fact that the upgrade rate was
well it's relatively low but they still
managed to sell more iPhones in the most
recent quarter now the implications of
that of course is that the iPhones the
added iPhones they sold were from new
customers so therefore with a larger
upgrade expanded expected sorry a more
significant upgrade expected later this
year tends to be named the iPhone 10
possibly the iPhone 8 that implies that
more people existing customers will
upgrade of course one of the debates
around Apple is how much credit they
should get for its services business
some claim that they don't fully get
that priced in the way other companies
do is there any evidence that investors
are repricing that source of revenue it
was one of the things they did highlight
in the earnings call but I think there
is still very much the expectation or
the perception that Apple is the iPhone
company iPhone accounts for two-thirds
of their sales what they do in services
is significant for any other company
they do they did last year about 24
billion dollars in sales and services
but that's a very small percentage of
the overall pie and so you know that's
not really affecting their valuation of
this stage so when it comes to Apple we
once again focus on the hardware which
is the next-generation phone you
mentioned it will be either iPhone 8 or
maybe iPhone X is something that we see
in analysts notes a lot
UBS saying that there might be augmented
reality included in the phone this would
be a game-changer right well Tim Cook
actually did an interview with the
British press last week with the
independent where he said that he sees
augmented reality as a yes as
significant a phenomenon as the iPhone
itself whereas the smartphone but
augmented reality is a very broad
spectrum you know it's at the the likes
of Pokemon go could be considered
augmented reality they're quite fun
rudimentary you could take that to any
number of levels you know things where
you show your environment around you and
you can see what's in shops and all that
kind of idea now we don't know if
something is going to come in the next
i phone to what extent it will be full a
are right understood now in terms of
actually getting the stock price to the
next level it's at a record high but
everyone will be looking at what the
company does with regard to its excess
cash dividends or buybacks Apple only
announces that once a year when it comes
to buybacks uh are we looking at more
cash being returned to shareholders I
think that's always going to be likely
they're extending that although what's
interesting if you look at their history
they've tended to extend the buybacks
and the dividends in the times when
there is a product lull it kind of props
up the share price I saw some analysis
recently which said that without those
buybacks their stock price would be
closer to a hundred dollars the
expectation will be you know as I said
significant upgrade perhaps implies they
won't need to do those kind of buybacks
anymore to drive the stock growth but
the more significant consideration is
what the Trump administration is likely
to do in terms of reducing the tax costs
of really operating offshore cash
absolutely that could free up money for
that kind of that kind of movement